joining us right here on the rich eisen
show getting set to
uh join the rest of the sunday night
football crew with whom she
works so expertly i just love the
broadcast
nothing nothing gets missed on a sunday
night football broadcast
and uh part of that reason is because
michelle tafoya is on the broadcast and
she's here
on the rich eisen show prior to chiefs
and raiders how are you michelle
well i feel like i should be more
interested in the jets right now
i can't i can't get myself there i'm
sorry you know what michelle it's the
rich eisen show my name's on it
i wear everything on my sleeve uh the
jets will be relevant
pretty much uh on a handful of occasions
the rest of this year and uh
i don't think if i'm not mistaken there
will be no jets flex games
coming in no we are not planning on
flexing into the jets at this time
it would take um it would take a minor
miracle well i mean the only one that i
think al would accept would be the jets
uh
at the rams that would be the only
exception
yeah if he can drive to a game he
doesn't care who's playing
that'll be it right before christmas too
i don't have to get on a plane in
december
uh how are you michelle i'm great thank
you so i mean
your your job in the era of covid um
how how are you walk me through your day
your
week what do you do to get ready here
the week stays pretty much the same you
know it's and it's it's seven days a
week and you're prepping and you're
researching and you're talking to people
but when you get to the stadium on
sunday that's where things come to a
a major change you don't walk right out
onto the field like
we normally do and and that's where you
get a lot of work done
um but you can't do that so we have this
sort of green room area where we collect
ourselves for a while
and then once it's time to go you know
get in position
i'm in this area that they call the
operational zone we call it the moat
because it indeed feels like like you
can't
it's like you're right outside the
castle you're right exactly
and i can't go in and if i do try there
will be
you know reptiles so it's we're in this
moat
and it's the place where also all the
nfl films cameras are the majority
i think we have one or two handhelds
allowed on the field but i am not
allowed on the field
so that changes but i'll tell you
something it's been interesting having
that perspective of being
up a little higher than field level
because you can see uh
as you well know you can see a whole lot
more so there are some advantages
it's weird at half time you go to talk
to the coaches and i'm up in that moat
and i'm leaning over the wall and
they're trying to hear me and i'm trying
to hear them and we're talking through
masks and everything's muffled and you
just do your best
and then post game you know usually
you're down there and you can get a
sense of the player that you're going to
talk to and
you can talk to more than one player and
you know you really get a sense of body
language you can watch them respond to
your questions their facial expressions
there's none of that now because we're
up in
the moat and there's a camera on me and
there's a camera on him
and we sort of just talk to our cameras
so that's really i think the biggest
difference
i don't talk about a tough gig michelle
i mean again uh uh and
you know i understand what tough gigs
are in the era of covet i'm just talking
about in the construct of of covering a
football game here
i mean coaches if they're losing by two
scorers they're getting their
ass handed to them in the first half and
there you are trying to ask him a couple
questions to get
all of us at home knowledgeable and you
have to repeat yourself because you're
talking through a mask and
oh my gosh that is that can
not be it's not fun you know it's
probably the least
fun part of the day but you know some
coaches really surprise you
and they can be you know like a bruce
arians or a mike zimmer they can be
not having success but come out of the
locker room like it's just another
wednesday you know and and so
it's uh it really does depend on on who
you're talking to but they've all been
gracious enough to participate in it
and uh and we we just do the best we can
and and
you know we can't go to actually
chris and and fred goodell our producer
and our director dress cop they do go to
practice
the rest of uh we have to keep that
number to a minimum we don't have the
same number of staff
on the ground uh for the games as we
usually do so it's just it's been really
weird
and we can't go out to dinner together
well i mean with al too i mean that and
i mean please you know yeah he likes to
he likes to tell stories and i miss that
storytelling yes he likes to tell
stories and not
eat a single vegetable and be proud of
him correct or even have it placed
near him he brags about never eating
anything green i know he actually brags
about it
it's very weird it's uh you know it's i
it's amazing he's still alive and
right he healthy if he orders the
lobster biscuit a restaurant he'll say
make sure there's no like chive or
anything green in it at all
it's down to the you know the the
minuscule stuff
well he is look his attention to detail
is legendary there's no question about
that true
uh michelle tafoya here on the rich
eisen show all right let's combine uh
both endeavors here
uh sunday night football chiefs raiders
your sports
uncovered podcast is all about gruden so
let's hit that
uh right here you spoke to a whole bunch
of people including gruden himself
about him who he is and what makes him
tick so i'll give you the floor here
on that subject matter for a big huge
game for the las vegas raiders against
the chiefs
it is a huge game and coincidentally i
spoke to gruden and we did his interview
right after he beat the chiefs uh at
kansas city earlier in the season so
he's in a great mood
driving the bus around arrowhead driving
the bus victoria victory lap
yeah yeah we we talked about the extra
mileage and so forth but
he was in a really good mood but you
know he always is i've known him because
we worked on monday night football
together on espn for a while so
it was a good conversation um and it was
really i think the most interesting
stuff is going back to the trade
that night after the tuck rule game loss
where he was traded to tampa bay
and it was a really interesting look
into the whole thing
um and the other guy talked to that i
found fascinating was derek brooks and
what it
what the transition was like to have
tony dungy leaving tampa
and john gruden coming in and what tony
told him
uh because everyone was really sad to
see tony go you know the players
loved him they couldn't believe it and
and what tony told him and then what
john gruden said when he came in it's
really
really interesting to see how that team
then
winds up in a super bowl against the
oakland raiders so it's it's a
fascinating story we talk to a bunch of
people and it's uh
hopefully you'll find it entertaining
yes and uh that's
the sports uncovered podcast where all
podcasts can be acquired
um what's the scoop right now best you
can tell about
the defenses in practicing right yeah
it's it's it's crazy
it's really wild um and you know i've
talked to guys who have had been
homebound when they've been on that
covet list and what that's like and
really
it's difficult because one of the things
they can't do is go in and get their
usual treatment you know get stretched
out get their massage get their
chiropractic whatever
they've got to stay home and so that
whole week
they are on the zoom meetings and then
you know something will get pushed to
their ipad
the film of practice and they'll watch
practice that way
and then you know they get out they get
out of get on the floor and stretch
themselves do some foam rolling and
that's what they do
and then they come back in the one
silver lining i'm told is
if they are cleared to play sunday their
bodies have been well-rested
and they're really fired up to play and
that's about the only silver lining uh
to this but it's
right at this point and we're talking to
them later today we don't know exactly
and i don't even think they know
who's going to be eligible on sunday
it's crazy michelle
i know and i i know everybody's got a
role with punches and
you know um you you were gonna have a
raiders game
on sunday night against tampa but that
had to get moved because of covid and
you wound up
uh with the game of the year pretty much
uh to date with seattle and arizona
one we saw two last night but yeah you
know i know you got a roll with punches
and
the you know the raiders have been
rolled by the league
um you know for covid violations um
putting it all together now you got to
take on the chiefs coming off of a bye
week where they're pissed i mean
they are pissed about that bus ride
around arrowhead you know
i think they really are they didn't like
that very much uh
and you know like you said rested and
with just so
many many offensive weapons and
uh you know so it's yeah this is tough
when you take a defense that hasn't been
able to be
on the field together and i was talking
to jeff heath
uh last night and he said look there is
no replacement
for being on the field for practice and
going through that you know that
game speed with your teammates and so as
much as they're going to try
and overcome all of this you know if
they're at a disadvantage there's just
no question they do have the home field
uh but they yeah they're facing a not
very happy opponent
no and they're the only team to have
beaten kansas city i mean there's so
many
you know uh intangibles
as if kansas city doesn't already have
you know a monopoly on the tangibles you
know right
right there it it and the fact you can't
even practice
with your starters is significant one of
my favorite stories in the league and
i'm sure one that you'll be
highlighting michelle on sunday uh is
josh jacobs i think he is phenomenal
uh i i think he could be the reason why
it doesn't matter
in the end obviously it does matter but
when it comes down to it might not be
uh a game changer that the defense
doesn't practice all week he has an
opportunity to keep
mahomes on the sideline i love that kid
and his whole story
here's a little preview for that he is a
great story and uh he's had a
relationship with marcus allen that has
proved really helpful to him
and i talked to marcus last night and so
he gave me some really good tidbits
about the
the the knowledge and the wisdom that
he's passed on to this kid and
and why he's so easy to cheer for so um
it's it is great stuff and he is an
exciting guy and
and now everyone knows about him he's
not a secret anymore so
um you know target on the back as they
say yeah i think uh
if i'm not mistaken i just saw some
stats from the nfl network kind of past
my my eyes over the weekend that jacobs
is
over the first two years putting up
numbers that allen didn't even
put up there you go so you know he's
by osmosis getting stuff from allen
that's making him really successful but
um you know in a couple areas in
particular that
that that marcus has talked to him about
is his past protection and
running at the goal line and and and of
those two things of course
marcus was very very very very good at
so it's
it was a really interesting conversation
and hope to get that story in on sunday
before i let you go michelle i won't put
you on the spot and talk about your
your your favorite coaches to to talk to
today these days
what about coaches who have since uh
retired or any part of your career who
you thought that
you loved or got a good story to to tell
ourselves it probably has to be at the
top of the list and
you know i got let go by cbs after five
years and it was after my first year
covering the nfl for cbs and you know
who called my house
bill parcells and and i was shocked and
he called to tell me and he left a
message because we weren't home and he
said you know i just want you to know
that i love you and i love working with
you and
i know things are going to work out
ahead so uh and
and i was there in dallas the night that
he pulled drew bledsoe and put in tony
romo
and i remember that he came out of the
locker room and he sort of looked at me
and said like
come here and so i walked over there and
i said what's going on he goes
i'm putting tony romo in and that was
one of the stories of the year you know
so that
that's i i've i have great love and
respect for that man
i love it he said come here huh yeah it
was like he kind of like pointed like
you know get over here now i got
something for you yeah
happens to be the benching of drew
bledsoe and then comes tony romo who
hardly
america's hardly ever heard of no
kidding
yeah it was it was cool and in the
meeting heading into that game i
remember him having a twinkle in his eye
when he talked about romo
and said and i said you know is he
really ready to come in and he said
yes he is and no one and the rest of the
crew believed me when i said you know
there's a chance romo might come in this
game they're like no
no no no no and sure enough at halftime
it proved to be the case
you know and interestingly enough
michelle the the coach
uh you know from the parcells tree uh we
all know
about belichick um sean payton out there
as well
he's got a big quarterback decision he
apparently he's made in taysom hill
no i'm wondering if there could be any
shades here obviously we know what romo
turned into
and brees is the gonna be the guy who
comes back from injury when he comes
back but
what do you think of this move having
spoken to sean as much as you have
he loves taysom hill he loves him and
what's not to love
i mean that you know there's and this is
a guy who
that is who he said he's going to start
correct yeah okay
i mean he hasn't said it he hasn't said
it but ian rappaport and adam schefter
have and so that's good enough for
me yeah well you know it was interesting
he had told us peyton had told us if
drew were to get injured in a game they
would put jameis winston in to finish
the game
and then they would prepare taste them
the following week so that's apparently
what we're looking at
taysom's got it all uh he can do
anything
and provided he's had the week to
prepare and get an offense ready to roll
i mean he's been in drew brees back
pocket for
since he's been in new orleans and he
said drew has been great about just
letting me follow him around learn to
prepare
and and get ready for games and so he he
feels ready he's always wanted this
opportunity you know
he's been a great team player and done
whatever the heck they've asked
but this is you know this is an
opportunity for him and
the question is when does drew brees
come back you know this isn't a simple
injury right but when drew does come
back he'll finish his career and
you'll probably end up working with him
one day peacock network
yeah well well we're we're we're all one
big happy family no doubt about that
but you know it's funny before i let you
go i'll tell this story too
um they've heard it here all on the show
but my favorite parcel story
that when i uh first took the gig at nfl
network
um i got to spend some time with paul
tagliabue here and there
and i just asked him you know what
what's your favorite story involving a
coach that you've ever been around
and he answered he told a parcel story
where he went to practice
in new jersey when he was a coach of the
jets standing on the 50-yard line and
the jets defensive
line is going through goal line drills
on the goal line
and parcells is just ripping everybody
by name
ripping everybody by name and he says to
him you know
bill we're the same age i can hardly see
two yards in front of me how do you
see 50 yards down the field and he takes
out of his coat he takes a list of names
he goes oh i can't see that far he goes
i got a list of names of people who i
knew i was going to get on their ass
today
he goes i'm on number three stick around
i got seven more to go
oh that's priceless and that is that is
not surprising at all it sounds just
like him
thanks for the call michelle have a good
cast great rest of the season if we
don't chat uh we'll do this again
sometime
thanks for chatting thank you guys take
care that's michelle tafoy again check
out her podcast sports
uncovered she spoke to taurico derrick
brooks
gruden himself hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here